Well, hello there.
Hey Jennifer, I was going to ping like, do we need to reschedule as I saw you on focusing? Yeah. How are you? How's everything?
No, I think we're okay.
Yeah.
I'm good, things are good. How are you?
I'm good too, so seeing at the window behind you, I always see a sunny weather outside.
Yeah, it's a little rainy today, but it'll it'll come.
No.
Yeah, no, I'm just saying, like, because of the image that you...
Oh.
If only it looked like that outside right now.
Yes.
Yeah, how's the weather over there? It's raining and so it's colder or it's Sunny.
It's all right. It's a typical spring day. It kind of starts out cool, gets a little warm as the day goes on.
Yeah.
Okay, and how are things going on here and how the, how's the volume and everything with the new customers coming in? How's that?
Um, it's definitely picking up. I think Ketan has mentioned that he's feeling it a little bit more.
Yes.
Lately, compared to what we were at before.
I get it.
Yeah.
That's great. Aaron's gonna join or should we start?
No, Aaron's on another client call right now, so we can get started.
Oh, no worries. Okay, so thanks for joining and the agenda sees the same, no changes. For highlights, we have seen that his performance has improved and in the recent discussion that I had, he is really happy to work with FL.
and he really feels supportive from F12. So from you and Aaron basically, so he feels a lot comfortable. He finds himself an extension of your team. So remote, I do not see any challenge and I see the happiness.
Awesome.
in him, I, that's what I sense because I've seen some engineers who are not happy working with some of the partners because they do not feel the same warmth. And some of the engineers I do see, like they want to move to F12, they're asking me to move them to F12. I said, no, we cannot release you from the current role unless there is a replacement or something like that.
But yes, so that's the overall that I see from Gian. And he's really happy. And one thing that stand out, I was doing a quarterly discussion. And from next time, I'll make sure like whenever I do a longer discussion with him, I'll ping you beforehand around.
a day back or maybe two or three hours back if it's a sudden discussion. But yes, I'll definitely inform you. And that was a miss on my part.
And honestly, he can just schedule it. So we use our, we're really pushing to use our calendars in ConnectWise. He can just schedule it in ConnectWise. Just so if anybody's looking or planning out the day or planning callbacks, we clearly see, you know, he's got a call with you at this time. So we're not double booking him and we're making sure we've got that phone coverage.
Yeah.
Yeah, usually in a month or so I do connect for 10 or 15 minutes. And on a daily basis I have an internal team connect. I just tell them if you have any work or if you have any call, just ignore the call or if you think you have some avail and anything, you can join. So sometimes he joins and as soon as he gets the call, he drops off.
Of course.
So that's it, but disconnect quarterly, it's kind of a 30 minutes or 45 minutes connect to review the performance for the last quarter. And obviously I'm doing some other checks as well, where I'm trying to find out how the work is, how he's liking it, ITBD and the dev tools, so all those things I'm doing.
I've really started this quarter. So from next time, when I do book a meeting with him, I'll let you know. And I'll also ask him to book that time off on his calendar. So usually it's once in a quarter that I do this big meeting. So otherwise, it's just a 10, 5 minute connect and that can be taken out any time in the month.
Of course. Yeah, we want to make sure that he's got the time with you to dedicate for those meetings. Like those are important.
Okay.
Yes.
important like connections. So we just want to make sure that he's got that time and he's not feeling rushed.
Yeah.
Yeah, and moving on next, like, Selena was onboarded on 7th April and Pam started with F12 on 13th April. My focus with Pam is to get onboarded with Polaris ASAP. I already set the expectations up before the interview and after her selection.
that you will get Katie, you will get knowledge transfer, you will get time, but we are kind of in a rush and for first two months I will not ask you about your KPIs. I'll just focus on that you learn the things, you get well versed with the customers and you're able to.
communicate better with the customer so that the F12 experiences does not go for a toss. I will not ask you to meet your matrix, explain what her matrix are and how many calls, how many tickets that she should do, what's her CSAT and what's her utilization going to look like, but I...
clearly explained my expectations that no, I'm not going to look after your KPIs as of now, but yes, I'll definitely look forward that you are going in the right pace for understanding the customer's environment and
She's sitting besides Kian, so that should help her understand the things better.
Yeah, it's perfect because I think he's going to train her on dial pad today because it's just with them being right next to each other, it's a lot more seamless that way.
It's easy. Yeah. And that takes a lot of burden on Aaron as well. And that's why I wanted specifically to, because even Selena was sitting besides her. And that's why I wanted her to take that seat, because it's very easy. She was asking me that she should.
Can she sit on server? Does she die clearly explained to her? No, that's not possible, but yes, keep working like this and you would be well-versed, and that's what I explained to her.
Okay, anything for Khan you have any anything positive or negative or any feedback that you have?
Just the usual, right? The transport and the coming, you know, making it on time.
Yeah.
Yeah, but that has improved. We haven't seen any delays happening. Today, specifically in whether there is heavy rainfall and that was unexpected. So, and I was going forward back and forth with Pam and the transport team to get that fixed and that's why I responded, I informed you late.
But this was one of instance. I have already spoken with Pam and I was spoken with transport team. So this should not be an issue because before Pam was on boarded and I knew this situation, so specifically asked how at what time does she reach office generally. So she reaches office around.
10 or 15 minutes prior to our shift. But today this was an off-case scenario and for Ketan, believe me, every day I'm tracking his cab and now he's on time. We are not seeing those issues. So I'm going to continue this so you do not face it.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is like it's since Monday, right? Like he was logged in late Monday, so we've got four days that are like, I really love a good stretch of more than four days where where he's in and logged in by 9:00.
Yeah, and I'll be very honest with you. The problem was that on Monday, there were some rights, not in the city where he lives. So those two cities are adjacent and the office where we have, there were some rights. And because of that, a transport was
diverted and that's why we had this issue. We knew about it and I said to him like everything was on track, everything was there, but these situations came and then again it was on me because I was working with him. Sometimes, yeah, it doesn't. Vishal told me like you could have informed me, I could have taken care.
But getting on the calls, I am sometimes not able to get off the mobile for long, like that takes around 20, 30 minutes. So that was a delay on my end. But yes, I'm tracking that cab on daily basis. I do chat with him, WhatsApp, like if that's working fine, are you on track? So that's it, and if there's any delay.
I just get into a conversation with the transport team and so, and Vishal has been helping me in this, where he has been putting that extra pressure from the leadership end, from the senior leadership.
Don't be too emotional, Shashank. I know you're doing a lot when it comes about Kian and now Pam. Good morning, Jennifer.
Yeah, it.
Thank you.
Yeah, and I know like things are going to happen, right? Like people are going to get sick. There's going to be accidents. Like I know though, like they happen here too, right? It would just be nice to get them a little bit more or less frequent.
Yeah.
Yes, and that that was we what we are working on and we are trying to reduce it as much as we can.
Absolutely, absolutely, yeah.
I appreciate that.
This is exactly what I was referring to, Jennifer, when I was saying that we have created an internal service improvement plan, how to resolve these, you know, transport and timely arrival issues over there. So we are working with other department exactly what Shashank was referring to, transport team, admin team, and we are in a regular conversation with them because
This is the P1 for me, you know, on a light to note, I always say that your wish is my command, but I always want to ensure that, you know, I know this has been a pain area for you and you have been really, really patient over there. I really appreciate that. But I, this is something we are working and even I would love to stretch it for more than four days.
Yes.
That, you know, we had we are doing it fine more than that, actually, for more than four weeks, more than four years, that is when my my agenda is, so fingers crossed we are doing fine. Thank you so much.
Perfect. Yeah, and I realize this isn't a key on problem, right? Like, he's fantastic. This is, you know, outside of his control. It's not like he's sleeping in every day or, you know, getting to the pickup location late. You know, it's not, these are things outside of his control.
Okay.
Yep.
Thank you for understanding. Yep, back to you, Shashank.
Thanks, Jennifer. Not to lose from previous meeting and performance analysis, although I have shown Selena this time, but from next time I'll remove her data and start adding PAMS data. Obviously, she got on boarded in April, so we might have...
Very less data for BAM, but still I'll do it.
I think she has one ticket right now, so probably not a whole lot to report on.
Yes, okay, so Ketan utilization is good and I'm not going to talk about Selena. So overall we can see the improvement in Ketan with the regular talks and everything. I see the things are going in the right direction. And moving on to the ticket closures, we can see the ticket closures are improved and in mid of March we got...
two new customers with Polaris. And as we discussed the last time, like ticket closures will now improve. So I am hoping like this should improve well. So it should reach the 160 mark where we are able to service more customers and close more tickets.
Yeah, and like to be fair to him, he has more tickets to work on now than he did back in January. So there's more opportunity for closes.
Yeah.
Yu.
Yeah, I am hoping that he crosses a 160 mark, so that's good. Moving on next, CSAT analysis. So Kian scored 100% surveys over 35. So that's really a good thing. We see a lot of surveys for him. And specifically in my Connect.
that I had, he mentioned that he loves to get that CSAT, positive CSAT, and that is a great motivation for him. Anytime he gets a CSAT with good comments, he said like, I really love it and that's what motivates me to do better job. This is one of the biggest thing as a technician.
that I see in him. Not all that engineers do focus on this matrix. They do not get motivated by this A lot. They do get motivated, but the amount of energy that he gets from this, that's huge. That's what he explained to me.
I'm glad to hear that, because to me, that means he cares about the people that he's working with, if he's caring about their feedback. Like that, you know, at the end of the day, we're all people helping people. So that really makes me happy that that's his feedback.
Yes, that's it. That's correct. So overall leaves for Ketan, one unplanned, 4 planned, total 5 leaves, 3 holidays. And for Celine it was 2nd to 6th March, 27th March to 7th April. For the credits, Vishal is working on it with the billing team.
And we'll adjust, there are two things to it. First of all, Vishal would add the credits to it. And secondly, he would stop the billing for the time for which Selena was not available. That is from 7 till 13th. So that would be done in the next billing cycle and the bill that we send.
So, thank you.
to F12. So that would be taken care of. Yeah.
Perfect. Thank you.
I appreciate you guys taking care of that.
Yeah, and going forward, my focus is with Pam to make sure that I make that constant communication with her so that she understands all the customer base, and that's my focus. Vishal, you joined in later, and I already spoke about it, but yes, my focus is not on KPIs for the...
for April and May, that would be more in June. But yes, for April and May, my focus would be that she gets well versed with the customers, because every IST has a different customer base. They need to be handled differently. So that's what I am seeing.
No.
Mhm.
And that's what my focus is on. And Kian obviously is training her. Kian loves his job, so he'll make Pam love her job as well.
So yeah, like so far, I mean, it's only been a few days with Pam, but she really strikes me as somebody who is just eager to go to jump in to, you know, help people. So I'm really looking forward to having her on the team, like even in our huddles, right? She's pretty quick to jump in and share as well, which is
is really nice and you know we want her to be comfortable as part of the team.
When I first spoke to her and I when I explained about F12 different ICs because this is one of the things that we do when we align any engineer, we let them know that this is a customer format, this is what you would be working on so that we do not see the backlashes from the.
engineers like, oh, I do not want to work on this or that. And so that it's not a misalignment. So that's one thing that I specifically do when I shared F12 profile in general and what the engineer feedbacks are. She said, like, I want to work with this kind of.
Yeah.
Partner. So that was her initial response. And when she got the interview and everything, she was very curious. She was pinging me, how did the interview? I said, like, give me some time, I'll update. We are still waiting for a feedback. So that's where she was very curious about it.
That's fantastic. Yes, I think she's going to be a fantastic addition to the team. And just, you know, Keon, Pam, and then we have got our friend who is our other tier one, right? They're really the face of our team. Like they're the first point of contact when somebody's calling in.
So, just so happy that we've got, you know, a team there that really...
Seems to care and seems to want to, you know, help those people on the other end of the phone.
Like, I am definitely sure, like with Pam skills, she would be able to crush it and she would become a superstar just like Khan.
Awesome.
Okay, Vishal, you want to add on anything?
No, I'm all good. As long as Jennifer is happy, that makes me happy. So I'm all good. Again, thank you so much for all your patience, Jennifer. You know, I really, really, from the core of my heart, I appreciate all your support.
Sameer.
Of course, and I appreciate you guys supporting us as well. And, you know, I'm looking forward to getting, you know, Pam. I know she's probably a little bit bored this week with all the training and all the, you know, the necessary paperwork and things like that that need to get done. But I'm looking forward to the next week where she's going to actually talk to some
you know, clients and be a little bit more client focused, client facing. So I'm really looking forward to seeing how she, how she does with that. I think she's going to do fantastic.
Sure.
I hope she performs fantastically and I'll be following up with you, Jennifer. Just me or Vishal would be following up with the group to just read your thoughts, initial thoughts about how her performance has been in the week because that is when we want to closely monitor.
and see if there are any improvements or any feedback that needs to be shared with her. Just like general so that it does not go haywire or she does not feel like I'm not getting the right feedback.
Yes.
Something like that.
Yeah, I would appreciate maybe like even just a quick Team touch base next week when she's actually had a chance to. It's tough this week because there's just so many videos and so many...
you know, policy requirements and all of that that needs to get done. So I know, I have a feeling she's feeling a little bit bored this week. You know, my words of advice would be to just kind of enjoy that because next week we'll get her client facing and it'll be a much quicker pace, which I think she's going to do well with.
Ashish.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yes, and I know like with all the engineers who have been aligned like first week they all feel bored and the next week they start become champions.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, it's a necessary thing you've got to go through, right? Is you got to stay awake through those videos. That's the first like check mark on the onboarding list.
Yeah, okay, great. Great to hear that. We'll let's touch base on Friday. We'll just ping and if a call is required, we can do a call as well. I'll just touch base on that and we'll capture initial feedback for Pam.
Ohh.
Sounds fantastic. Thank you guys for the time today. I appreciate it.
Thanks, Jennifer. Thank you so much for the time.
Awesome. Have a good one.
You too, bye.
I...